mais d'abord en marge de la pandémie les
surdoses explose à montréal et ailleurs
au pays
des médecins sont engagés dans une
course contre la montre pour trouver des
solutions
boum boum boum boum boum boum on verra
en un seul mois on a eu 23 décès ce qui
est énorme
c'était du jamais vu
moi c'est pas vrai que je vais laisser
mes passes et amour et depuis un an les
travailleurs de la santé qui combattent
la coved 19 dans l'ombre
quelques-uns de leurs collègues sont
engagés dans une lutte sans merci contre
une autre crise de santé publique
une épidémie meurtrière dans l'angle
mort de la pandémie
mais si on a un mur haut mais les photos
de nos patients qui décèdent puis
habituellement c'est 20 patients par
mois un passant par deux mois c'est
quand même beau course et des jeunes
notre mur est plein depuis cet été
depuis le début de la pandémie et
surdose explose à montréal comme
ailleurs au canada comme société on doit
se poser la question quand on voit des
gens mourir comme ça on doit se dire il
ya quelque chose qui est pas normal
j'ai pris la décision de fermer toutes
les entreprises et tous les commerces le
23 mars 2020 le premier ministre
françois legault
mais le québec sur pause
tout à fait remis d'un coup du jour au
lendemain le centre ville c'est nous et
les policiers
la majorité des organismes qui viennent
en aide aux consommateurs de drogue sont
contraints de fermer leurs portes le
temps de s'ajuster aux mesures
sanitaires cactus montréal qui offre des
services d'injection supervisée est seul
à tenir le fort ah ben non on est obligé
d'intervenir sur des surdoses qui
survenait dans les toilettes chimiques
en avant deux chaînons dans la ruelle en
arrière sur la rue dans notre salle
d'injection aussi faut savoir qu'avant
la pandémie on n'avait en général une
surdose au semaine ou une surdose haut
de deux semaines est là depuis deux mois
de juillet on a commencé à vraiment de
ça s'intensifie en salle où on a eu des
périodes où c'était plus d'une sur deux
par jour
[Musique]
la fermeture des frontières depuis le
début de la pandémie a chamboulé le
marché noir
la cocaïne et l'héroïne produite à
partir de champs de coca et de pavot se
raréfient plusieurs consommateurs se
tournent vers des drogues 100%
synthétique dont les drogues
synthétiques cette drogue pour être
fabriqué domestiquement donc ici au
canada par exemple benoît archambault et
chimistes à santé canada son équipe du
laboratoire d'analysé des drogues
identifie les substances saisies par les
corps policiers parmi les échantillons
se trouve de plus en plus de nouvelles
molécules
on a des surprises à tous les jours
parce que évidemment les substances
surtout les substances illégales
ses larmes en écoutant sont retrouvés
dans les landes il y pharmaceutique
sous les apparences d'héroïne comprimé
pharmaceutique
on trouve des cocktail de substances
plus toxiques les unes que les autres
c'est que c'est un marché qui n'est plus
du tout sécuritaire et une roulette
russe à chaque fois parmi les drogues
qui font de plus en plus de décès se
trouve le fentanyl il est 40 fois plus
puissant que l'héroïne
tout le monde nous l'avait dit dès que
le fait un aileron
la situation devient catastrophique la
docteur carole morissette de la
direction régionale de santé publique
suit l'évolution des surdoses à montréal
depuis 2014
les chiffres ont doublé à partir de
l'été dernier avant la pandémie on avait
un marché où il y avait présence
d'héroïne
l'héroïne est une drogue qui crée
beaucoup de dépendance mais qui amène
les personnes à avoir une vie beaucoup
plus stable
quelqu'un peut consommer trois fois par
jour et avoir une certaine un certain
confort et même fonctionner 13 minutes
le fentanyl à une durée d'action
beaucoup plus courte
donc ils doivent augmenter leur dose et
doivent consommer très très souvent dans
la même journée et ils sont toujours un
étonnement coup à peu près moi ça fait
15 ans que je traite des patients
dépendance de piau et puis ce qui se
passe actuellement j'ai jamais eu
donc c'est un peu le cauchemar le comme
anticipé la docteure marie ève gauthier
est à court de moyens pour traiter ces
patients à l'hôpital notre dame
c'est la première fois aussi qu'on est
obligé de les hospitaliser des les gens
aux soins intensifs pour des sevrages
ultra compliqué on est obligé de donner
des doses intraveineuses on est obligé
d'appeler nos collègues en
colombie-britannique pour ce qu'est ce
que vous faites avec ça on ne put
l'expertisé ici au québec
la colombie-britannique à une triste
longueur d'avancé un traitement de la
dépendance d'un quartier d'un ton east
side le fentanyl fait des ravages depuis
des années en une journée sur une
période de quatre heures on a eu 16 sur
12 l'une après l'autre
dès 2005 le docteur martin scheckter
professeur à l'université de la colombie
britannique a testé un traitement
audacieux pour détourner les
consommateurs du marché noir à la
clinique round les casseurs reçoivent
une dose d'héroïne 2 à 3 fois par jour
pratiquement les gens pensent que si on
donne de l'héroïne aux toxicomanes ils
vont en vouloir toujours plus ce n'est
pas le cas les patients trouvent la dose
qui leur convient avec leur médecin ou
leur infirmière et en moyenne c'est la
moitié de ce qu'ils peuvent recevoir ils
n'en veulent pas toujours plus juste
assez pour rester confortable
[Musique]
dans certains pays d'europe dont la
suisse la prescription d'héroïne
pharmaceutique existe depuis des
décennies au canada l'équipe du
professeur chez que tester son
efficacité dans le cadre d'une étude
baptisée naomi
les chercheurs ont recruté 250
toxicomanes essentiellement à vancouver
mais aussi à montréal
tous avaient tenté les traitements
conventionnels de désintoxication mais
avait échoué
la moitié a reçu de l'héroïne sous
supervision médicale
les autres ont reçu de la méthadone le
traitement standard
[Musique]
le taux de rétention des patients qui
prennent de l'héroïne est beaucoup plus
élevé ils ne prennent presque plus de
drogues de rue parfois plus du tout ils
peuvent se trouver du travail et
retrouver une vie stable
les deux tiers des participants qui ont
reçu des ruines pharmaceutiques ont
diminué considérablement voire arrêter
leurs activités illégales
[Musique]
beaucoup d'entre nous vivions dans la
rue ou fusion des séjours en prison à
l'hôpital
maintenant on arrive à trouver du
travail un logement comme les gens
normaux je suppose
les résultats naomi ont été publiés dans
le très prestigieux new england journal
of medicine en 2009 mais le gouvernement
fédéral de l'époque a refusé d'autoriser
les médecins à prescrire de l'héroïne à
leurs patients toxicomanes
à montréal le programme a été
complètement délaissé à vancouver les
patients ont dû s'adresser à la cour
suprême de la colombie-britannique pour
continuer à recevoir de l'héroïne
thérapeutique l'héroïne pharmaceutique
doit être importé de la suisse à fort
prix martin scheckter en collaboration
avec l'ancien chef de la santé publique
de la colombie-britannique a week end au
travail a lancé une unité de production
ici même au canada la société fair price
for abba produirait des doses à une
fraction du coût
edwards président je sais que c'est fou
une compagnie pharmaceutique qui ne veut
pas faire de profit
notre mission c'est de combler un vide
en santé publique au meilleur prix
possible au québec aucune clinique
n'offrent encore des opioïdes
injectables comme traitement de
substitution
la docteur marième faye et se bat depuis
cinq ans pour en ouvrir une
ce serait impensable si j'avais un
traitement qui fonctionne comme ça au
niveau du cancer et que je ne ne
déployait pas ça ferait longtemps que je
me serais fait lancer des roches à la
fin 2019
la docteure de yi a finalement reçu le
feu vert pour déployer des cliniques
front des opioïdes éjectable au québec
il ne s'agira pas d'héroïne mais
d'hydromorphone c'est un dérivé de la
morphine prescrit comme anti douleurs il
est connu sous le nom commercial
dilaudid ou dix lits dans la rue la
pandémie a retardé le projet mais selon
la docteure gohier c'est avant tout la
stigmatisation de la dépendance qui
freine le traitement des patients
c'est comme si on a choisi comme société
que la consommation de substances
étaient mal puisque ces gens là devait
payer pour répondre des conséquences de
ce qu'ils ont fait alors que la personne
qui fume la cigarette qui mangent
n'importe quoi je fais une crise
cardiaque
elle va avoir accès aux soins pour lui
posera jamais queste
[Musique]
pour lutter contre les surdoses des
organismes communautaires distribuer
massivement des trousseaux naloxone cet
antidote aux opioïdes s'administre sous
forme d'injections intramusculaire ou à
l'aide d'un vaporisateur nasal avec les
nouvelles drogues synthétiques
il faut parfois six voire sept doses
pour sauver une vie encore faut t'il
quelqu'un pour les administrés en
période de confinement c'est loin
d'aller de soi on a laissé tomber les
gens on les a laissées mourir tout seul
chez lui on demande aux gens de rester
tout seul on recommande aux gens de ne
jamais consommer soeurs nous il ya des
gens malheureusement que maintenant
qu'ils sont morts mais qu'on a ranimé 15
fois vingt fois et à chaque fois ils
nous remercient de les avoir ranimé
à chaque fois bon mais à manier ils ont
été tout seuls ils ont fait une surdose
et sont morts mais ça c'est un drame qui
sont morts en toute logique ces gens là
soient encore en vie
au chum la docteur julie bruneau déplore
le manque de moyens pour traiter les
patients toxicomanes
quand on pense un traitement des
opioïdes on a deux molécules on à la
méthadone inventé dans les années 30 40
filet lui prennent leurs fines inventé
dans les années 50 60
est-ce qu'on aurait ça pour
l'hypertension le diabète jamais de la
vie
la méthadone et la buprénorphine qu'on
appelle plus souvent suboxone sont deux
au pied aux ide à effet prolongé ils
empêchent les symptômes de sevrage
pendant 24 à 36 heures
les personnes qui suivent ces
traitements peuvent se rendre à la
pharmacie tous les jours et prendre
leurs médicaments devant le pharmacien
ce que plusieurs juges humiliant
actuellement on est des traitements pour
les gens hyper motivés à arrêter mais
c'est pas ça qu on ose pas ce qu'on fait
dans d'autres maladies là on veut des
traitements pour tout les stages à la
fois pour ceux qui viennent de commencer
qui savent pas trop à la fois pour ceux
qui sont dépassés qu'ils ont tout essayé
la docteur julie bruneau avec des
collègues du centre de recherche du chum
a participé à l'étude
optima dans le but d'offrir plus de
flexibilité aux patients la moitié des
participants à l'étude a reçu un
traitement de méthadone selon les
modalités habituelles
les autres ont reçu des comprimés de
suboxone qui pouvait apporter à la
maison et ce qu'on veut voir c est ce
que ça donne les mêmes résultats
et est ce que les patients sont plus
satisfaits
je
depuis le début de la pandémie la
docteur bruno a aussi collaboré avec
l'équipe de cactus montréal pour
permettre à des toxicomanes de consulter
les médecins du chum par visioconférence
avec la télémédecine en 8e tout à coup
vous vers un monde et ça nous a permis
de raccrocher des gens qui étaient
complètement d insérer depuis des années
qu'ils avaient pu renoncer à tout ça et
là ce que ça permet c'est de changer le
rapport aux médecins parce que le lien
fonctionnel et avec nos intervenants
ceux qui sont dans la salle et c'est
beaucoup moins intimidant pour eux
d'avoir le médecin de l'autre côté d'un
écran même si on a une équipe médicale
qui est exceptionnel note mais dans la
perception mais ça change tout comme les
médecins et les chercheurs cactus
montréal veut s'inspirer de vancouver
pour protéger les usagers contre les
substances contaminés du marché noir
dans tintin east side ceux qui achètent
des drogues dans la rue peuvent les
faire tester avant dé consommer des
services est offert gratuitement comme
ici chez getrag tested fournit une forme
de contrôle de la qualité qui n'existe
évidemment pas sur le marché noir
si les consommateurs découvrent que leur
drogue sont contaminés et n'en veulent
plus on les aide à les éliminer
cactus montréal veut déployer ce même
service
même si les gens n'ont pas forcément
tous venir analyser les substances
l'information va circuler dans le milieu
et des gens mettent en place des moyens
pour prévenir les risques pour les
militants et de plus en plus de
spécialistes de la santé publique il
faut aller plus loin pour protéger les
toxicomanes il faut leur donner accès à
des drogues sécuritaire
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'approvisionnement sûr ou safe citoyen
en anglais
si on veut vraiment à des fins de santé
publique réduire les décès c'est pas en
offrant à un petit nombre de personnes
des traitements qu'on va réussir à
vancouver certains toxicomanes aux accès
des drogues sécuritaire dans un cadre
beaucoup moins contraignant que celui de
la clinique cro star ça fait des années
que je travaille ici que je vois des
gens faire des surdoses avec des drogues
contaminés et que je les réanime pour
moi c'est évident qu'il faut leur offrir
une alternative
le docteur barkindo installé une machine
distributrice d'hydromorphone à côté
d'un centre d'injection supervisée
plutôt que de se réveiller le matin en
manque et de chercher désespérément
comment se procurer leur prochaine dose
ils viennent ici et ressorte avec ce
dont ils ont besoin
tous sont considérés à haut risque de
surdose
je me concentre sur les personnes qui
n'ont plus de contact avec le système de
santé
mon premier objectif c'est de les garder
en vie
une fois qu'ils sont stabilisés grâce à
un approvisionnement sécuritaire il ya
plus de chances qu'ils réintègrent les
services sociaux et médicaux les
participants ne renonce pas
nécessairement aux drogues de rue on
trouve encore du fentanyl dans leur
urine
ainsi 80% des drogues qu'ils utilisent
viennent de la machine et 20 %
proviennent de la rue c'est 80% moins de
risques de surdose à montréal la docteur
carole morissette suit de près les
résultats de marque tendo pour évaluer
la possibilité d'installer des machines
distributrices sur son territoire
c'est certain que c'est sur la planche
de travail d'examiner la faisabilité
d'avoir ce genre de projet en attendant
quelques médecins du québec dont la
docteur marième faye et accepte de
prescrire des opioïdes un des patients
pour remplacer les substances qu'ils
achètent sur le marché noir
c'est pas vrai qu'on va attendre que le
gouvernement fédéral que les
gouvernements embauches qui ont
décriminalisé qu'on légalise nos
pensionnaires meurt à tous les jours
c'est des gens qu'on connaît c'est des
gens qu'on aime en 2020
la docteure douillet a publié un guide à
l'intention des médecins prescripteurs
pour encadrer la pratique du safe supply
mais seule une poignée de médecins
qu'elle appelle les courageux lui
emboîte le pas
si c'est juste sur des épaules de
docteur que ça repose d'essayer de
retirer les gens du marché les sites on
n'y arrivera pas il faut que ça soit des
mesures de santé publique beaucoup plus
robuste
de plus en plus d'experts en toxicomanie
demande au gouvernement fédéral
d'assouplir l'accès aux drogues dures
comme la cocaïne ou l'héroïne les plus
militants rêvent de l'égalisation comme
cela a été fait pour le cannabis
mais pour en arriver là il faudra gagner
l'opinion publique et surmonter les
jugements moraux
[Musique]
essentiellement ce qu'on est en train
d'imposer aux consommateurs de drogues
actuellement c'est la peine de mort
c'est ça qui plane sur leur tête
est ce que comme société on accepte de
condamnés à mort une part importante de
la population puisqu'il faut considérer
que la consommation de drogue est très
répandue dans notre population et à tout
âge tous sexes confondus et tous niveaux
sociaux
est ce que l'aco ville nous montre ce
que quand on a une crise de santé
publique comme la crise des opioïdes
et aussi on est capable de se retourner
de bord puis de prendre des moyens
donc je pense que là il faut qu'on
enlève ce stig moeller qui ne fonctionne
pop qui est délétère pour tout le monde
puisqu'on passe à l'action qui confesse
je sais implanter ce que la science nous
dit qu'on devrait implanter depuis des
années